avete mai giocato a pallacanestro
riconoscereste quel rumore che fa bum
bum della palla che avanza sul parquet
immaginatevi questo rumore in un
palazzetto vuoto
immaginatevelo adesso pieno Che
differenza c'è secondo voi vi racconto
quel suono con i miei occhi da piccola
C'era una bambina che giocava a basket
fino a quando ha dovuto scegliere perché
nella città dove viveva non c'erano
squadre femminili vicino casa con cui
giocare non lo sapeva ancora ma la mia
vita sarebbe stata una vita di scelte in
poco tempo in pochi secondi con il
sangue freddo che scorre nelle vene non
permettere di dirti a nessuno che non
sai fare qualcosa se hai un sogno
proteggilo la ricerca della felicità è
la sintesi perfetta della mia vita li
già le regole Sognavo di diventare un Il
mistero di polizia e invece sono
diventata un albero di basket amavo e
amo correre con la palla ma ho capito
che sono più veloce a farlo senza ho
iniziato a correre maratone
ultramaratone Ok facciamo un passo
indietro torniamo al bum bum del
palazzetto pieno e vuoto il palazzetto
pieno per me è un arrivo una Finish line
una sirena che suona e tutti festeggiano
per la vittoria ma il palazzetto vuoto
cos'è davvero era un sogno il mio sogno
era correre per la quinta volta la 100
km del Passatore da Firenze a Faenza una
delle ultramaratone più belle dure ed
entusiasmanti che ci siano Controlla il
incontrollabile direbbe il mio amico
Tommaso non avevo calcolato la pandemia
stop metabolizza Veronica Alza la mano e
chiedi aiuto Ok ma chi in primis ad un
amico che mi stava aiutando negli
allenamenti lunghi Giovanni detto lui
per unire l'utile al dilettevole corre
spingendo il passeggino con i suoi due
bimbi la mia 100 è diventata la nostra
100 Volevamo solo fare rumore proprio
come il suono della palla sul parquet
volevamo aiutare facendo quello che più
ci piace correre il primo step È stato
disegnato una 100 km attorno il
perimetro di Bologna Perché non sapevamo
come si sarebbero nute le restrizioni e
strega comanda colore bianco sono nate 7
mini tappe che chiaramente noi avremo
corso tutte di fila L'idea iniziale era
correre e raccogliere fondi Ma perché
coinvolgere solo un'associazione 7 7
come le tappe quando doveva essere una
data da ricordare la fissazione per i
numeri ci fa decidere in un battibaleno
10 10 20 20 perché 10x10 fa 100 perché
ci potrebbero essere tante valide
ragioni ma il momento ve ne dico solo
una
Avete mai visto gli occhi degli altri
felici per averli aiutati a raggiungere
un piccolo traguardo il battito del
cuore in quel momento sono in maniera
unica da soli Però non potevamo fare
tutto abbiamo iniziato a schematizzare
abbiamo iniziato a sognare ho fatto
qualcosa di nuovo ho chiesto aiuto ho
chiesto aiuto ad un allenatore Questa
volta non potevo fare di testa mia e
improvvisare una gara non erano ammessi
errori non correvo per me capite avrei
corso per 7 Onlus per regalare sorrisi e
speranze a tanti bambini e non solo Enea
Non credeva le sue orecchie mi dava per
spacciata dopo la prima settimana di
allenamenti insieme non avevo mai
seguito una tabella in fondo lui era la
mente dietro le mie sveglie giornaliere
mi sono riscoperta un esecutrice precisa
Ma è uno sgarro Ma è un Red Che
significava una X allenamento non
conforme poi c'è Rebecca psicoterapeuta
un professionista che vi auguro di
incontrare sul vostro cammino lei
avrebbe pensato alla mia mente a quel
controllo il controllabile in qualsiasi
situazione fisica climatiche ed emotiva
infine c'erano loro gli amici dell'alba
in the city coloro che tutti i martedì e
venerdì alle 6:00 del mattino ti
aspettavano davanti la statua dei
Giardini Margherita a Bologna in
quell'occasione sapevo che non sarei mai
stata sola avevo una squadra di amici un
team che sarebbe diventato parte viva
della 100 km e come si poteva chiamare
questa 100 se non centro del dono 100
come i chilometri che avremo percorso
100 esattamente come quelli del
Passatore il dono era prestare le nostre
gambe per tanti nuovi progetti
della maratona ant Michele per tutti
fondazione Umberto Veronesi e il
progetto Pink bimbo tu agevolando Io
tifo Sveva Loro sono le mie nuove Sette
sorelle
adesso che ve le ho presentate vorrei
dirvi perché abbiamo fatto tutto questo
perché ho donato ore e ore di miei
allenamenti per non prendere una
medaglia vera
credevo di non essere capace di seguire
tutti gli allenamenti mi sbagliavo tutti
i miei limiti mentali sono crollati sono
stati superati Credevo di poter fare
tutto da sola mi sono ritrovata chiedere
aiuto ad un nutrizionista ad un
allenatore ed una psicoterapeuta Ognuno
ha fatto magnificamente il proprio
lavoro
crediamo di essere indistruttibili non
lo siamo crediamo di essere infallibili
non lo siamo crediamo di non riuscire ad
aiutare noi stessi come potremmo aiutare
gli altri ci sbagliamo in una distanza
così lunga l'imprevisto però è dietro
l'angolo ma c'era una fiamma che non
poteva essere spenta nemmeno con una
pioggia improvvisa andare oltre i propri
limiti fare rumore fare suonare
sull'asfalto le scarpe da running
l'aceto del dono voleva essere tutto
questo lo è stato abbiamo corso 13 ore e
14 minuti ma in tutto questo tempo cosa
abbiamo fatto ogni tappa aveva dei
capitani legati alle associazioni per
motivi che richiamano lo scopo stesso
dell'associazione al nostro fianco
avevamo amici in sella alle bici da
corsa che ci passavano acqua e cibo così
come disegnato dal nutrizionista siamo
stati in onda su Radio Deejay con Laura
e Rudy abbiamo fatto dirette Instagram
voglio ringraziare dopo aver tappa le
associazioni e per invitare a donare non
sono stata un attimo zitta bugia durante
la seconda tappa sapete i tre Capitani
hanno aumentato il passo un po' troppo
rispetto alla tabella concordata in
quella tappa abbiamo creato un'ora di
vantaggio lo stesso che ci porteremo
fino alla fine in quel momento di
silenzio ho avuto una crisi una di
quelle che ti fa salire il cuore che ti
svuota le gambe respira pensa alle tue
sorelle Pensa che le due gambe corrono
per loro mi son detta
ho pianto senza farmi sentire dagli
uomini al mio fianco
in tutte quelle ore c'era un ritmo
scandito da una parola che suonava come
legge passo e tutti andavamo di passo
per recuperare 321 andiamo e si
ricominciava a correre abbiamo fatto
tutto ciò che desideravamo ridere
sorridere emozionarsi ogni volta che il
contagiri delle donazioni aumentava il
nostro cuore batteva un po' di più
abbiamo capito che non eravamo soli così
come ogni famiglia che si trova a
chiedere aiuto ad una delle Sette
sorelle abbiamo battuto il record di
quanto pensavamo di raccogliere abbiamo
battuto il mio record sulla 100 km di
ben tre ore insieme non abbiamo ricevuto
una medaglia ne abbiamo ricevute 10.000
esattamente come 10.000 euro è poco più
che siamo riusciti a raccogliere e
donare in parti uguali alle sette
sorelle non poteva finire così Io tifo
Sveva ha condiviso con agevolando il
gusto preferito del gelato di Sveva per
ricrearlo nella gelateria Bolognese dove
lavorano i gare Giver Michele per tutti
ha supportato Io tifo Sveva per la
creazione delle prossime uova di Pasqua
personalizzate
andrei corsari della maratona e Michele
per tutti sono in contatto per
l'acquisto di carrozzine dedicate ai
disabili e chissà che gara bolle in
pentola Potrei continuare ancora quello
che però vorrei lasciarvi come messaggio
e che tutti possono correre una 100 km
perché non serve necessariamente correre
per fare del bene tutti possono fare
rumore senza disturbare nella notte Il
vicino di casa suonando la batteria ma
donando 100 sorrisi quando il vicino ne
avrà bisogno
la 100 del dono diventerà
un'associazione a sua volta con lo scopo
di far conoscere altre realtà come
facendo la cosa che ci riesce meglio
tramite eventi sportivi 100 come i
chilometri che ci sono da Firenze a
Faenza gli stessi che abbiamo corso alla
100 del dono di come destino quello che
non ti aspetti Ma che affronterai o come
obiettivo quello che ti dai E che
raggiungerai e né come ninna nanna
quelle belle che farete ogni volta che
aiuterete qualcuno o come orgoglio
quello che vi porterete dentro per tutta
la vita fate rumore sorridete ripetetelo
quante volte volete Grazie